this is a little weird because I'm not
usually in the videos at the beginning
but I just wanted to ask you guys real
quick to turn on the notifications
button on my channel right next to the
subscribe button is the slow Bell if you
click that you'll get notified every
time I put up a new video that way
you're not missing out
other than that today is Saturday and
I've titled Saturday surprise Saturdays
if you watched the video yesterday then
it would kind of make sense basically I
mentioned that every once in a while I
would put up with surprise new project
on Saturdays today is one of those days
it's a project called a game of
questions and either a punch a couple or
a couple of friends and I give them a
list of questions and I told them to
take turns asking each other questions
on the list I think it turned out pretty
good and I hope you guys enjoy it here
it is okay so what are you names
Emma Michael Amy how long you guys been
dating 11 eleven months and four days in
1440 yeah you can start whenever you
want what is a mistake you see me make
her fatally
to savory seasons the juices what has
surprised you about me to get on
what are you learning from me
on the spot
paulien is like stuff that she did when
you travel
[Music]
like who did studying abroad and most
that we did up there pretty adventurous
probably how to like
how to talk to people because you can
talk to anyone and I'm more shy and
you'd see to me like colic actually be
able to like hold conversations with
people
finicky
who has more power in our relationship I
make plans so you
what scares you the most these days
[Music]
if they it's the clown
probably what I'm doing after I graduate
yeah
and what has surprised you about me good
evening father
I'm not t-shirt I don't know what bother
disease
the roommates
how do you describe me other people
that you're nice and caring because
you're like a mama's boy
and I'm told my whole life story about
you you tell me you don't like the beat
what do you remember from the first time
we met the nurse that we met yeah I
guess let's go after that play that game
it was pretty funny
Louis I can't we play there we put the
third yeah guys are you yeah you want to
answer that dude but what do you
remember from for the first time you
guys met fire smile
[Music]